[Music]
the screen monkey show with how Rodney
what in the world today we ask are you
ready for some football ow not what I
meant
are you ready for some fantasy football
yes I'm not talking Atlanta Falcons I'm
talking Millennium Falcon what do I mean
you're about to find out let's take our
hands on the quarter live on the field
all right guys it has always been a
dream of mine to play fantasy football
actual football with fantastical
characters and we're making it happen
today but it's not a free-for-all we got
a certain set of rules here okay each
player gets one power play where they
can use their superpower once and
holding once all games must be
officiated by the most logical creature
in the universe
a Vulcan you don't have a Vulcan just
ask your most honest friend Thank You
Spock to help me play fantasy football
the way it was meant to be played from
FX as the league Paul Scheer
Paul how are you great to see you thank
you so much for having me at the
inaugural fantasy fantasy football event
I've come in the easiest cosplay costume
I can think of Nick Fury it's just
really a jacket thank you for not going
blackface you know I go classic Nick
Fury what do you say we pick our teams
let's do it I'm gonna pick a true leader
of men Cobra Commander flash you with me
storm trooper come on
Baroness you over here you kick ass
Dumbledore come on down destro I think
you're gonna work really good with
Baroness good luck great team guys look
at here
[Music]
what are you doing who are you kicking
that to me power-play good effort there
you go sorry my depth perception is off
with the eyepatch there we go take it to
the house good kick somebody get it
Gandalf
can't drop that oh you're playing like
Eric Bana out there alright guys bring
it in bring it in I'm gonna call a power
play
stormtrooper just shoot anyone in your
way yeah whoa pop challenge the play
here come on
stormtroopers always missed right coach
is challenging to play stormtroopers you
always miss I have my 20 sided die here
you have to roll at least a 10 for each
one of the hits to count
who are you again darth nihilus right
right Mike hit somebody out there Mike
we bring it in you guys bring it in
you I hate to say this guy's but seems
like some of you are giving up out there
Dumbledore what's your real name Alex
Alex wait just come on hurt somebody out
there we have one play left one play to
win this entire thing you know your hop
I know you're sweaty these costumes
can't be comfortable but what I'm gonna
tell you is clear eyes full hearts can't
lose
I could have given up that day when the
Balrog was trying to get my friends but
I was like hell no over there is their
time over here is our time today we
celebrate our Independence Day guys
let's seize one moment of glory before
we have to take off these costumes and
go back to the real world let's go out
there and win come on guys
[Music]
we can do this
all right guys
swimmers on me let's do it amen great
game I think you were a little hard on
these guys you know all right I'll see
you later hey whoa you shall not pass no
pass no I'm shall be later took this way
too seriously damn it yeah don't feel
bad for that stormtrooper he may have
missed his shots on the field but he's
got three more Star Wars movies to
redeem himself special thanks to my
nemesis Paul Scheer he's super funny and
so does his show the league
check it out on FX also work out them
glutes and play your own fantasy
football
just don't let George Lucas on your team
he's got some great ideas but it'll keep
revising the playbook until it's
unrecognizable then he'll end up caring
more about selling toys and the quality
of the game that's all for now I'm Hal
right Nick bye-bye
don't forget to watch Twilight breaking
dad's where dad's answer Twilight trivia
for their daughters we made an 11-year
old cry